okay so batman is a character that i've
always been fascinated with i've
collected hundreds of graphic novels for
him platinumed all of the arkham games
several times and poured over every film
and tv show starring the dark knight
that i could find ever since i was a kid
what i've always loved about batman is
that he's someone who can be mulder to
fit almost any message that you want to
put across but at the heart of him there
still remains the fundamental belief
that justice must be upheld whether it's
the campness of the 1966 version the
darker more graphic timber intakes lego
batman the animated series batman v
superman or the grounded nolan films
every iteration of him feels like it's
valid i'm kind of ashamed to admit it
but when robert pattinson was first
announced as playing the character i
kind of shook my head and thought like
many that we'd be getting a
twilight-esque take aimed at teens just
a few years prior dc had massively
changed zack snyder's vision into
becoming the abomination that was
justice league and i wrongly assume that
they'd taken ben affleck out the role to
make things more like the mcu however
every single trailer every single tv
spot has made me realize that i couldn't
have been more wrong and the upcoming
batman film in my eyes has the potential
to be one of the best comic book movies
ever made it can be cruel poetic or
blind
but when it's denied
it's your violence you may
find in every interview that matt reeves
gives he just seems to get it and when
looking on liner comics the other day i
came across the collection of graphic
novels that is releasing alongside the
film this box set includes batman year
one the long halloween and also ego the
first of these tells the story of james
gordon transferring from gotham whilst
bruce wayne arrives home after his years
training abroad together the pair learn
to put their differences to the side and
come the end of it they form an alliance
that will help to take down corruption
in the city the long halloween is one of
my favorite graphic novels of all time
and this murder mystery focuses on
batman stopping a mysterious killer
called holiday from carrying out attacks
on the mob the book very much inspired
the dark knight and this year 2 story
feels like the closest thing we'll ever
get to the godfather being adapted into
a superhero story lastly his ego
something that i was surprised to see in
the lineup but after thinking about it
it makes a lot of sense the darwin cook
story follows batman failing to stop one
of the joker's henchmen from ending his
own life instead of facing up to his
boss racked with guilt he returns home
to the cave and bruce and the batman's
psyche split down the middle and they
both go back and forth over what it
means to be batman and what the future
should hold bruce very much has to
battle it out with his toughest enemy
yet his own ego and through this
self-exploration he learns what it means
to be batman it's a story that has
always fascinated me and when looking at
all the trailers and teasers i think one
thing becomes clear this is a batman
story
who's swing
sorry now before you start calling me
captain obvious yet what i mean by that
is that it's very apparent that the
batman is the true face whereas bruce is
the mask every time we see him in his
civilian clothes bruce barely talks
interacts or even seems interested in
what's going on during the funeral scene
that was posted online he barely says a
word and is clearly only attending the
event because he wants to learn
information that will help out batman
this is something that we have seen
explored in other films like batman
begins but bruce was always put forward
as the more dominant personality and
even the playboy one had a footing in
there too however here bruce wayne just
seems like an afterthought and it very
much reminds me of books like batman
zero yeah in that bruce returned to
gotham and he immediately started
patrolling the knight locking himself
away in the cave through the day he had
no interest in being bruce wayne and it
was only after the first talk that
alfred made him even consider bringing
that side of his life into the light
that's very much the feeling that i get
from the matt reeves movie and the title
of batman seems so fitting because
that's all that bruce appears to care
about here is a mentally damaged man
filled with trauma who will do whatever
he can to make sure no one has to
experience what he went through he's
completely obsessed with being batman
and i think the film will very much
explore the course that infatuation has
on someone's life now on the other side
of this is the riddler and opposite to
batman the riddler
is asking for you
the killer left this for the batman why
is he writing to you
is trying to keep everything in order
the riddler is someone who will strike
the match to burn down everything just
so that he can rebuild from the ashes in
the film he will be attempting to take
down the high ranking members of society
because he was clearly affected by them
at some point in its life it very much
feels like something that was ripped out
of the man who laughs which featured the
joker he killed several high-ranking
citizens in gotham and even targeted
bruce wayne which we know from the
trailers is something that the riddler
will also be doing all of these pieces
come together to show that matt reeves
is pulling some amazing elements from
the comics and it demonstrates that he
fully understands the source material
what he's also done though is to create
something that doesn't necessarily feel
like it's completely based on any
specific element and everything from the
batsuit to the batmobile feels unique
and innovative one comic i haven't
mentioned so far as batman year 100
which i also think that you should
definitely pick up if you haven't set in
the future this batman fully immerses
himself in the role and even puts fake
vampire teeth in his mouth just so that
he can get into the minds of criminals
there's definitely a darkness to the
character and what reeves has done is
that he's translated this to every
single frame in his film cinematography
is something that is often said to be
lacking in comic book movies and a lot
of the time this is purely down to the
process in which these films are made
shot heavily on green screens or even
completely computer generated it's
difficult for directors to capture a
true look and vision for their films
however reeves movie for the most part
was shot on location either in glasgow
or on sets and the reason that we have
so many behind the scenes sucks on the
film already is because it was possible
for the public to go down and see what
was being shot this adds an authenticity
to the movie and it allows the director
to see what he's filming as he films it
he isn't sending this off to vfx artists
with a description of what you go in the
background he's capturing it himself and
because of this his movie looks
completely different from anything
that's come before i'm struggling to
think of a comic book movie that looks
as good as the batman does and it's
definitely got its own style that you
can instantly see from any imager
trailer if you placed distilled a frame
of it down with another movie from the
genre and asked someone to point out
which one was the batman i think they'd
instantly be able to tell because of
reeves ability to craft a unique style
this extends to his costumes and one
thing that always bugged me about the
mcu was the reliance on cgi once tom
holland often complains in interviews
how his spider-man doesn't have a place
where he can pee but when you look at
his films his costume is often cgi'd for
the final edit this is extremely
noticeable now in movies like civil war
and after seeing how good garfield's one
looked in the amazing spider-man it
makes you wonder why marvel have started
to go down this route the batsuit though
looks real and that's because it is this
feels handcrafted and the cowl that's
stitched together is somewhat
reminiscent of the one from gotham by
gaslight the armor feels like it was
ripped right out of an arkham game and
all of it has a practicality to it
that's difficult not to appreciate even
with half the budget what most comic
book movies get reeves has elevated
things to a level where it looks better
than most in the genre and he's really
shown why creatives should always be put
above corporations in a time where a lot
of comic book movies feel by the numbers
he's taking his own vision and style to
a level that will make this movie stand
out from the pack batman is a character
that has been done to death at this
point but somehow reeves and many others
constantly find new ways to reinvent him
and bring him back as someone who can
still be modern while standing for his
traditional values the action looks
incredible too and just in the same way
that zack snyder completely nailed the
warehouse scene in bbs the fight in the
smoke against the riddler's goons feels
like the perfect way to showcase batman
on film this is someone who's mastered
several martial arts and gadgets and
watching him dispatch people with ease
will never not be satisfying
[Music]
there's also the detective elements to
this film as well and some moments of it
feel like they were ripped right out of
silence of the lamps we know from tv
spots that bruce will also be using
special contact lenses to record crime
scenes and reeves has said that he's
really pushing this film so that we can
finally see batman as the renowned
world's greatest detective it's
something that we haven't had before in
live action and when going against
cerebral villains like the riddler
batman will need to be operating at that
level too now beyond this we also have
the world building in the movie and
reeves has managed to bring in
characters like catwoman the penguin
carmine falcone and other mainstays of
the universe in a way that makes it
flesh out gotham this is the city that's
so corrupt that the lines are often
blurred between the criminals and the
upstanding citizens and we see in zoe
kravitz's catwoman how people have to
walk the line in order to survive it's
something i'm fascinated with in film
and often the villains are the ones that
we relate to the most because we realize
just how easy it is to slip into
darkness that's what seems to be the
best aspect of the batman and i can't
wait to see if he too wrestles with
doing the right thing when he uncovers
just how corrupt that the city is from
the trailers it looks like even the
wanes will be pulled into it and exposed
for what they've done to a massive
fortune i think that the film is really
gonna put several moral quandaries in
place for batman to try and navigate
overall it seems like it's gonna be
incredible and i hope that you enjoyed
us discussing why we're so excited for
it obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the film below and if you're
hyped for it or not if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of the third
trailer for the batman which will be
linked on screen right now we went over
all the easter eggs we could find in it
pointing out some of the plot details
that we've unearthed and it's definitely
worth checking out if you're interested
in the film if not then thanks for
sticking through the video i've been
poor i'll see you on the next one take
care peace
you